so if you look at the trend
with and the speed with which human
genetics has progressed we can now find
thousands of genes involved in human
cognition
in human psychology in the emotions and
the feelings that we used to think are
uniquely learned turns out there's a
genetic basis to a lot of that
so the uh you know the
the human genome has continued to
elucidate
through these studies of genetic
variation so many different processes
that we previously thought were
you know something that like free will
free will is this beautiful concept that
humans have had for
a long time you know in the end it's
just a bunch of chemical reactions
happening your brain
and the particular abundance of
receptors that you have
this day based on what you ate yesterday
or that you have been wired with
based on you know your parents and your
upbringing etc
determines a lot of that quote unquote
free will component to
you know sort of narrow and narrower
scale you know sort of
slices so how much on that point how
much freedom do you think we have
to escape the the constraints of our
genome
you're making it sound like more and
more we're discovering that our genome
is actually has the
a lot of the story already encoded into
it how much freedom do we have
i uh so so
let me let me describe what that freedom
would look like that freedom would be
my saying oh i'm gonna resist the urge
to eat that apple
because i choose not to but
there are chemical receptors that made
me not resist the urge
to prove my individuality and my free
will by resisting the apple
so then the next question is well maybe
now i'll resist the urge to resist the
apple and i'll go for the chocolate
instead to prove my individuality but
then
what about those other receptors that
you know
that that might be all encoded in there
so it's kicking the bucket down the road
and basically saying well your choice
will may have actually been driven by
other things that you actually are not
choosing
so that's why it's very hard to answer
that question well it's hard to know
what to do with that i mean if
if the genome has
if there's not much freedom it's uh it's
the butterfly effect
it's basically that in the short term
you can
predict something extremely well by
knowing the current state of the system
but a few steps down it's very hard to
predict based on the current knowledge
is that because the system is truly free
when i look at weather patterns i can
predict the next 10 days
is it because the weather it has a lot
of freedom and after 10 days
it chooses to do something else or is it
because
in fact the system is fully
deterministic and
there's just a slightly different
magnetic feel of the earth slightly more
energy arriving from the sun a slightly
different spin
of the gravitational pull of jupiter
that is now causing you know all kinds
of tides
and slight deviation of the moon etc
maybe all of that can be fully modeled
maybe the fact that china is emitting a
little more carbon today
is actually going to affect the weather
in you know egypt in three weeks
and all of that could be fully modeled
in the same way
if you take a complete view of a human
being
now you know i model everything about
you
the question is can i predict your next
step probably
but at how far and if it's a little
further is that because of stochasticity
and sort of chaos properties of
unpredictability of beyond a certain
level
or was that actually true free will yeah
then yeah so the number of variables
might might be so
you might need to uh build an entire
universe to uh
to be able to simulate a human and then
maybe that human will be fully
simulatable
but maybe aspects of free will will
exist and where's that free will coming
from it's still coming from the same
neurons or maybe from a spirit
inhabiting these neurons
but again you know it's very difficult
empirically to sort of evaluate where
does free will begin
and sort of chemical reactions and
electric signals and you know and
you